bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de 7,8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 7 mars
du métal à voisins le bretonneux pour
cette septième édition mais ta sauce
mise sur le métal alternatif groupes
amateurs et tête d'affiche se
partageront la scène rade mais reprend
vie cinquante ans après sa création
l'oeuvre de jean louis barrault retourne
sur scène un spectacle de troupes
foisonnant pensé par hervé van der
meulen et 27 films en compétition ce
week-end c'est la neuvième édition de
l'ombre d'un court le festival
international du court métrage de jouer
en josas deux jours de projections pour
décerner dipri une folk douce aux
accents rock et la rambo liten caroline
biojout ce week-end avec son groupe
autodidacte et passionné ils font la
première partie de pommes à l'usiné à
chapeaux de rambouillet nous avons
assisté à l'une des répétitions
c'est l'histoire d'une femme qui est
heureuse dans la vie un métier des
enfants la musique les amies étudiantes
infirmières en semaine menaces d'un
groupe le week end
caroline bioshock depuis son enfance la
rambo liten commence son parcours
musical par le chant en troisième donc
j'ai été élu soliste de la chorale des
yvelines et j'ai fait ma première scène
en fait et c'est là que je me suis rendu
compte que je voulais plus arrêter que
c'était trop bien et du coup je me suis
inscrite à la mjc à des cours de chant
donc là ça fait 7 andré
et ensuite j'ai acheté une guitare pour
pouvoir composer les textes que
j'écrivais depuis plusieurs années et
j'en avais marre d'attendre après des
copains pour composer et c est jamais
pouvoir faire des choses moyennes de la
variété folk rock caroline bio écrit
influencé par daniel balavoine gaël faye
et massive attack
en septembre dernier elle sort son
premier album avec ses quatre musiciens
elle est subtile allez juste voilà mais
ça c'est normal
ouais ouais il fait passer des faits
passés de belles émotions quoi elle est
très sensible
elle est très sensible à beaucoup de
choses elle fait vraiment ressortir
danse et musique
[Musique]
une voix cristalline sur des
compositions personnelles caroline
billaud et ses musiciens remonte sur
scène le samedi 10 mars
[Musique]
deux jours de concerts à la salle de la
torah voisins le bretonneux les 9 et 10
mars prochain c'est la septième édition
de métal ce faire l'événement métal de
metas haussé son coordinateur est en
plateau avec nous bien monsieur le
plongeon bojan bonjour alors le fil
rouge de cette année le maître mot c'est
le métal alternatif
exactement comme chaque année d'ailleurs
septième édition donc on est super
contents de pouvoir remettre ça cette
année on a la chance d'accueillir cette
année huit groupes au total sur les deux
jours donc ça va bastonner à la salle de
la tour
attendez d'ambiance deux jours quasi non
stop avec quatre groupes à chaque fois
exactement le style différent ce que le
métal ce faire le concept justement
d'ouvrir sur l'esthétique métal parce
que le métal c'est devenu comme le
rock'n'roll un petit peu le rock
en fait c'est un peu fourre tout donc là
il ya une diversité de genres dont il y
en a un peu pour tous les goûts on
essaye d'avoir cette fraternité
il a même testé qu'on ne s'attend pas du
dancefloor métal du death trash du métal
progressif
sescousse et des différences comment
dans les sonorités peut-être parfois on
parle de violence souvent que le métal
un peu de hargne en a peut-être qui sont
plus calmes oui bon ça a qui y en a qui
sont un peu plus violents entre
guillemets enfin plus extrêmes je dirais
pas violent parce que justement les
notes de ce rapide ou plus aiguë
voilà exactement il ya
j'avais pas le mot violence parce que
généralement d'ailleurs public métal
c'est des gros bisous nous mais oui à ce
côté extrême et puis à une musique un
peu plus on va dire accessible quand
remonte dans le temps les groupes comme
les et une victoire pole c'est le début
du métal sans poser les bases voilà
exactement mais c'est vrai que bon il ya
quand même des gens un peu voilà
singulier ans j'ai envie de dire comme
aussi dit arsène qui fait qu'ils
proposent et dancefloor métal est par
exemple un écueil croome
là on est sur du dob métal rock qui
évolue aujourd'hui quand même plutôt sur
un côté post rock mais qui propose
quelque chose de très intéressant et
très original injustement oublié c'était
quelques groupes il y en a ce sont des
têtes d'affiché la santé des groupes
locaux et c'est le cas de assia sont
enfin le groupe et yvelinois et fondus
des scores moderne c'est ça complètement
mais en plus des scores moderne teinté
de james qui a aussi un petit sous genre
mais on peut dire ça c'est dans le
progressif alors originaire de maurepas
là ils répètent dans nos studios depuis
la rentrée et on avait envie de les
accompagner donc sur cet événement là
donc
en tout cas je pense qu'ils sont bien
motivés ils sont super contents de jouer
puis le public quand il attend avec
impatience ce si bien relevé il ya très
peu de temps ça permet de continuer à
peut-être aussi à progresser
complètement puis la scène c'est une
super expérience il va y avoir le
contact avec le public
bon pour certains il ya aussi
l'expérience de la scène le sac là ils
ont la chance aussi de pouvoir être
programmé avec des groupes justement de
têtes d'affiché nationales or ce que
c'est ça aussi but du métal cers et de
valoriser les groupes locale
avec des têtes d'affiché nationales
alors l'idée on a dit qu'on n'a pas et
des nations et des locaux et avant de
parler des têtes d'affiché en écoute un
petit extrait dacia
[Musique]
génial
alors ce groupe là ils jouent le samedi
10 mars avec gorod promethean et sting a
alors je le prononce très bien voici ces
sas estime qu'un cd groupe l'a un peu
plus
habituée peut-être à la scène oui mais
en tout cas stengel ils ont participé au
festival de bakken nous c'est un peu un
coup de coeur au système gars que c'est
un groupe que j'ai découvert l'année
dernière va un copain qui s'appelle
mathias originaire de la région de lille
et on avait vraiment envie de les
accueillir sur cette édition lorsque
vraiment un gros coup de coeur comme
assia on a envie de les mettre sur la
scène là elle promettait aussi là on est
plutôt sur un style qu'on a rarement
fait à l'association sur un peu du black
death symphonique
donc voila et on avait tous avec gorod
donc groupe de death métal prog voilà
plutôt technique
d'ailleurs mais tient à son public et je
pense qu'on va avoir pas mal de monde
aussi le samedi ça trouve super soirée
injustement ça c'est ce qu'ils vont
conclure cette septième édition parce
que ça commence le vendredi tout à fait
donc événement sur deux jours le
vendredi c'est comme nous sommes dit on
va avoir quatre groupes
le soir ça commence à 20h et ça se finit
à une heure là on a la chance
d'accueillir ways qui va commencer donc
aussi au plus tôt du point à mi chemin
entre le 91 78 qui propose un métal
alternatif
donc on peut être un jour un peu plus
calme par rapport aux autres mais une
belle énergie sur scène le chanteur il
chante partout il ya une sacrée voix une
sacrée barbossi on trouve ça beaucoup de
barbus généralement dont le style métal
et puis on applique room obligé d un
petit peu parler on va avoir
personne avant qu'on en parle jamais
parce qu'on écoute un extrait sera super
[Musique]
c'est plus la tête d'affiché du vendredi
soir peut-être j'imagine complètement
sidilarsen c'est la tête d'affiche super
original en tout cas on est super
contents de les accueillir on les avait
appuyé à fort longtemps l'association
sur une tour prend l'air donc là c'est
un peu le retour au sein ou des sources
non cotées indoor cette fois par en
plein air donc je pense que ça va être
super sympa justement d'arriver à
regrouper autant de groupes avec des
styles si différents
comment vous les découvrez c'est lors de
rencontres j'imagine que vous faites
beaucoup de festivals aussi oui alors
durant la saison on ne connaît
quelques-uns à les avoir
d'autres concerts effectivement il ya
deux aspects il ya en effet les
tourneurs qui nous contactent ça arrive
net qui proposent leur groupe et puis
nous ont gardés qui on peut les
programmes et il ya aussi nous qui
pouvons des marchés quand nous intéresse
on a envie de les programmer et puis
surtout ce qui est groupe plutôt amateur
local où émergent en studio voilà il ya
les studios ont déçu tous à jouer puis
le réseau aussi le travail et les
partenaires les discussions les
rencontres et un côté très humain aussi
quand même un côté d'échangé de partage
dans la musique union
merci beaucoup au père michel personnes
est venue sur le plateau alors le
premier groupe qui va se produire sur la
scène donne rendez vous le vendredi 9
mars dès 20 heures
la semaine dernière vous les avez
découverts en train d'être installés les
voilà officiellement dévoilée la ville
de versailles le promoteur nexity et le
collectif qu'est 36 ans tiennent augurer
hier mardi 6 mars les fresques sur le
parvis de la gare versailles-chantiers
98 panneaux sur 120 mètres de palissade
réalisé par deux artistes urbains ni
pour moi c'était le plus important
travail que j'ai réalisé en noir et
blanc sa dg étudié versailles à l'école
en histoire de france l'an passé
aussi regarder la série versailles comme
c'est une magnifique opération est
qu'ils ont pris ils sont adversaires je
souhaitais que ce soit pérenne et donc
l'idée ce cas précis pendant le chantier
elle intègre dans le futur parking
souterrain de chanter elle n'avait
jamais été rejoué depuis 50 ans rabelais
est créée par jean louis barrault en
1968 dans le contexte libertaire de
l'époque
une oeuvre qui comme son nom l'indiqué
rassemble l'ensemble de l'oeuvre de
l'écrivain humaniste français ce retour
sur scène est à découvrir au théâtre
montansier reportages réalisés quentin
le frère une course folle de près de
deux heures cinquante avec gargantua et
pantagruel et panurge avec rabelais
hervé van der molen vous invite à des
voyages historique et littéraire
cinquante ans plus tard le metteur en
scène fait rejouer l'oeuvre de jean
louis barrault
c'est pas du tout pour commémorer les 50
ans de mai-68 puisqu'il avait créé sa
juste après mai 68 dont simplement je
suis tombé sur cette adaptation il ya un
peu plus d'un an et j'ai eu un vrai coup
de foudre
je trouve qu'il a su condensé pas toute
l'oeuvre de rabelais mais en tout cas un
parcours à travers toute l'oeuvre de
rabelais du début à la fin d'une façon
formidable
il y à 50 ans ils étaient 30 sur scène
aujourd'hui ils sont dix-neuf un
spectacle de troupes ou les comédiens
jouent chantent et dansent
[Musique]
des artistes qui investissent jusqu'à la
salle se mélangent aux spectateurs on
peut pas l'utiliser au point on
l'utilisé barreau parce que barron qui
s'était fait virer de l'odéon mai 68 a
créé ce spectacle à la rentrée après à
l'elysée montmartre qui était un sale de
catch donc ça se passait avec des
spectateurs tout autour sur un ring de
catch et il y avait énormément de choses
dans le rapport au public donc dans la
mesure du possible on essayait de le
recréer ici aussi au théâtre montansier
aussi loufoques se mêlent le jean
grivois et la parole philosophie propre
arables et l'humaniste et mel avait une
vie foisonnante et vivifiante et
toujours à propos du théâtre montansier
l'équipe de direction a été confirmé
pour cinq nouvelles années par la mairie
de versailles une reconduction jusqu'en
juin 2000 23 pour frédéric franck et
geneviève dichamp un duo misant sur une
collaboration alternative entre le
théâtre privé et le théâtre public
geneviève dichamp était l'invité de
grégory canal elle sûre dans le statut
de journal du mercredi 27 février on
écoute le théâtre vous trouvez vraiment
une place dans l'espace professionnel
on a aujourd'hui un public qui vient de
toute l'ile-de-france 50% de la ville
50% extérieurs dont des parisiens ça
c'est une vraie satisfaction
on a co produit des spectacles qui
tournent sur dans toute la france et
même quelquefois à l'étranger des
spectacles qui ont été qui ont reçu des
prix qui ont reçu vraiment la
reconnaissance du public et des
professionnels et donc c'est interdit
c'est ça c'est un rayonnement au-delà de
la ville l'exposition perception et
lison a pris fin ce week-end à la
commanderie des templiers une clôture à
célébrer avec une performance
d'improvisation musicale et de lecture
un spectacle suprenant qu'ont pu
découvrir nicolas gendry mais quel
ennemi dans une ambiance roues
je un solo de guitare des textes
évoquant le chaos
inspiré d'une série de photos prises par
richard du mort en 1994 au matin de
l'incendié du parlement de bretagne
les deux artistes olivier mellano et
richard dumas ont créé une improvisation
musicale abstraite ou les écrits sont
les seules matières de l'oeuvre on
connaît les éléments qui en ces cas le
texte c'est vous texte mais richard pour
les prendre n'importe quel moment et on
est vraiment on écoute l'un et l'autre
est en réaction par rapport à ce qui se
passe à ce moment là donc on fait on n'a
jamais fait deux fois pareil c'est la
première fois que cette manière qu avec
la guitare concédions fonce et puis on
verra comment ça se passe il faut sentir
le moment tels a résonné pour entrer en
résonance en a retenu ou en résonance
pour leur troisième représentation
devant un public les artistes ont voulu
également adapté en temps réel cette
improvisation face aux réactions de la
salle on prend l'ensemble des gens qui
sont là on sait ce qui
qui voilà qui est là et on n'est pas
qu'on n'est pas coupé de ces gens n'ont
pas coupé des gens c'est vrai que nous
sommes se forment un tout une recette
qui a fonctionné auprès de la
quarantaine de spectateurs présents à la
commanderie des templiers
c'était une performance
réussi au niveau contemplatif je dirais
ça mais les mots l'essence la musique et
le sens des mots moi je pars moment
j'entendais pas tout mais des mots comme
ça qui surgissaient comme dans un rêve
parfois comme dans un cauchemar
le rendez-vous à clôturer l'exposition
perception et illusions installé pendant
quatre mois et l'encours le public lui
en redemande
[Applaudissements]
pour votre coup de coeur à cinéma on
part pour les yeux d'elsa à
saint-cyr-l'ecole le coup de coeur du
cinéma les yeux d'elsa cette semaine
c'est les oscars ce sont les oscars
qu'on a vu arriver la semaine dernière
et dont nous aurons certains films dans
les semaines qui arrivent the phantom
fred cette semaine mais surtout le grand
film qui a un peu rafler tous les oscars
7 cette année la forme de l'eau the
shape of water le film de guillermo del
toro meilleure direction artistique pour
les décors meilleure musique pour
alexandre desplat meilleur réalisateur
pour guillermo del toro et meilleur film
est en effet c'est un oscar mérité c'est
vraiment pour ceux qui connaissent
quelques mots del toro ce réalisateur
mexicain qui nous a apporté le
labyrinthe de pan mais aussi pacific rim
par exemple plus récemment c'est
quelqu'un qui aime les monstres qui
aiment les histoires fantastiques les
histoires un peu baroque mais c'est
aussi quelqu'un qui aime les histoires
d'amour c'est quelqu'un qui aime le
cinéma est là dans ce film on entre dans
une amérique des années 50 pluvieuse
noir dans une sorte d'ambiance de films
noirs des années 40 50
et puis on va se retrouver dans une
sorte de film de mons des années 60
et puis surtout il vous allez être pris
dans une formidable histoire d'amour et
c'est pour ça que je le conseille à tout
le monde moi ça a été un très très grand
coup de coeur et j'espère que ce sera
aussi un coup de coeur pour vous à
partir du 21 mars et pour deux semaines
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa la forme de
lots de guillermo del toro
on pense que ça sature culture avec
notre nouvel invité frank gillett
bonjour vous êtes le président de
l'ombre d'un coup donc le festival du
court métrage de jouy en josas c'est la
huitième et dix neuvième
éditions alors cette année 27 courts
métrages en compétition mais en fait
c'est plutôt la compétition officielle
oui parce qu'il ya aussi mais aussi le
scolaire le scolaire qui est qu'on fait
le vendredi matin et après midi pour les
écoles de la ville
donc il ya sept films en compétition
scolaire et après 28 en compétition
officielle
l'idée d'associer les enfants
de mettre ça dans les écoles associées
pour montrer qu'ils ont leur avis aveux
mais oui alors avis à donner
pour l'heure
ouvrir aussi à l'esprit sur sur
différents thèmes différentes histoires
ils sont intéressés par le cinéma
ils vont voir des films d'animation en
famille ou pas et donc la façon des
films plus court plusieurs histoires
plusieurs personnages et donc on aime
bien aussi leur faire découvrir tout ça
il ya aussi la compétition officielle
qui elle va être sur les deux jours l'an
dernier vous aviez reçu un millier de
candidature bleus mais le succès cette
année le même succès oui c'est vrai
qu'on reçoit beaucoup de plus en plus de
candidatures et là on a reçu à peu près
le même nombre et c'est toujours aussi
difficile de choisir j'imagine pour
arriver à 27
oui ben oui c'est difficile parce que
on a beaucoup de choix et donc on essaye
de
c'est toujours un avis subjectif après
mais on essaye d'être le plus juste
possible en tous les cas nous on a une
grille de sélection
précise on s'attache au scénario on
s'attache à l'interprétation à la
qualité technique évidemment et donc
voilà c'est vrai que c'est pas facile
si la discussion en tous les cas dans le
comité dont on commençait avant ça doit
bien continuer après avec le jury dont
on est alors un tout petit peu tout à
l'heure ce que cette année déjà il ya
une nouveauté
oui il y à une partie spéciale sur la
sélection qui a lieu le 20 heures à 23
heures temps de vendre au 19 mars
vous allez faire une soirée de l'étrange
voilà on tente quelque chose cette année
de nouveau
c'est la séance de l'étrange le vendredi
à 23h30
donc c'est un peu plus tard mais c'est
propose des films un petit peu à la
programmation petit peu plus difficile
au programme des films fantastiques les
films de science-fiction et d'horreur
aussi pour attirer un peu plus un peu
différente qui viendrait pas forcément
au fait les mêmes
e
la tirer un peu plus les personnes plus
jeunes aussi qui sont férus de ce genre
de cinéma justement le court métrage ce
n'est qu'une finalement qu'une question
de durée
il y à tous les styles comme on porte
sous les pas du long métrage
oui il ya tous les styles nous on c'est
vrai qu'on limite à 20 minutes
les films qui sont en compétition et
ça va de vraiment d'une minute à
20minutes on essaye de proposer des
styles et des genres différents
on a juste voulu mettre un petit un
petit zoom cette année sur sur cette
séance de l'étrange qui on l'espère va
attirer du monde parce que ça va être ça
va être bien ça met un peu particulier
l'ambiance et le spectacle va être
particulier donc on espère que les gens
seront au rendez vous qui dit festival
dit bien sûr le jury comme toujours ces
composés de professionnels chez vous et
le président du jury cette année c'est
le réalisateur du ticou surnomme le pack
du court métrage
oui je sais pas si ça lui plaît vraiment
un homme comme ça oui c'est un
spécialiste du court métrage ça fait
depuis 1974 qu il en réalise claude
utile à réaliser filles perdues cheveux
gras notamment avec marina foïs
bienvenue au gîte chez nous ces trois
donc il a aussi réalisé des longs
métrages et il participe et le
collaborateur du festival de clermont
ferrand du festival des arcs et du
festival de trouville donc c'est
quelqu'un de guerrier il a l'habitude du
festival et du court métrage surtout
c'est ça qui est important
il anime des débats et des tables rondes
en sept festivals et il sait de quoi il
parle
justement c'est quoi la cie en quelques
mots la particularité d'un court métrage
mais il faut aller vite rentrer vite
dans l'histoire il faut aller vite
être vraiment très efficace dans
l'histoire et
dans la compréhension évidemment et oui
vraiment l'efficacité
le plus rapidement possible et comme
toujours chez vous vous favorisez les
changent à chaque fin de projection il à
la rencontre avec les équipes ou des
shins est important aussi
oui c'est important que les réalisateurs
les équipes de films viennent parler de
leur oeuvre et
donc on leur laisse la possibilité
d'avoir cet échange et ça aussi ça
intéresse le public d'avoir des
renseignements sur le film sur
l'histoire sur comment ça s'est passé
sur l'origine des projets donc on perd
mais cet échange avec les réalisateurs à
la fin comme en format qu'on voit moins
de temps en temps au cinéma c'est
diffusé apprend avant les longs métrages
mais à la télé on voit qu on en voit peu
à la télévision il ya quelques émissions
spécialisées sur
le service public notamment et sur arte
au cinéma
il ya de moins en moins d eau film mk2
le faisait encore récemment mais c'est
de plus en plus rare d'avoir un court
métrage en première partie votants à
quelqu'un avant lui même et en parlant
de rencontre j'en profite pour mettre
l'accent aussi sur la rencontre avec le
jury qui va avoir lieu le samedi après
midi à 16h30
donc là aussi j'invite tout le monde à
venir parce qu'il y aura un échange
justement parlez des changes le public
pourra échanger avec les membres du jury
qui parleront de leur parcours et de
leur carrière
il y aura des projections de films avec
les membres et g voilà donc y aura cru
dit il y aura jean louis tripp qui est
acteur et metteur en scène qui a fait
pas mal de télévision et de cinéma il y
aura david ferrer qui est aussi matière
les créateurs d'effets spéciaux et
coline d'inca qui est actrice et tout ça
se terminera le samedi avant vers 23
heures parce que ce sera la cérémonie de
clôture avec la remise des prix et bien
on a dit m il y en a une dizaine sayah
grand prix du jury le scénario la mise
en scène et l'interprétation
il y aura aussi nouveau film à venir au
festival ont fait un prix coup de coeur
il ya le prix des écoles et le prix du
pit bull et l'intérêt des échanges
pour bien comprendre le travail des
équipes merci franck bull est alors
équivalent à l'ombre d'un cours débutent
vendredi 9 mars première projection à 20
heures on passe maintenant à notre
agenda
[Musique]
au prisme jeudi 8 mars juliette vous
parle des années d'une jeune fille libre
les trajets solex les tubes de lait
concentré le son des pink floyd
lever de rideau à 20h30 au théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
helge un patriarche respectés et craints
en fête ses 60 ans famille amis sont
réunis un secret de famille révéler
extraits
[Rires]
christian
[Musique]
c'est toi qui joue de la musique
je le veux plus de musique christian
j'aime les gens mais j'en ai peur je
demeurais grande maison
si vous êtes plutôt musique les amis de
l'orgue de coignières vous donne rendez
vous dimanche 11 mars
la violoniste hildegarde feno et
l'organiste raphaël arnaud joue à
haendel vivaldi et rheinberger est
toujours à coignières les malins
plaisirs joue avec les proverbes chacune
des courtes comédies illustre un
proverbe connu au public de deviner
extrait sentir père citons comme nous
mais attendez c'est pas encore le moment
de tuer un dieu des preuves
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce site une culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mercredi prochain
[Musique]